Tonight I can write the saddest lines,...
...like for example,...
..."the night is shattered and the blue stars shiver in a distance."
"The night wind revolves in the sky and sings."
Tonight I can write the saddest lines.
I loved her and sometimes, she loved me too.
Through nights like this one, I held her in my arms.
I kissed her again and again under the yellow sky.
She loved me and sometimes, I loved her too.
How could one not have loved her great, still eyes?
Tonight I can write the saddest lines.
To think that I do not have her,...
...to feel that I have lost her,...
...to hear the immense night, still more immense without her,...
...and the verse falls to the soul like dew to the pasture.